angelina jolie going all in on brad pitt
[ __ ] bruh
you know what's weird is like
when celebrities get into beef i judge
their decisions within the beef based on
the characters they've played
so like like i love brad pitt in all the
movies that i watch him in yeah right
brad pitt to me is the guy from motions
11 12 and 13. he would never abuse his
kids he loves his wife and he's an ideal
husband so and also a criminal though is
[ __ ] maleficent this is a lion ass
[ __ ] that's a good point she would lie
she a weird-ass girl she would lie in
order to take advantage of this
situation she's trying to get custody of
them kids brad pitt probably didn't even
want to buy them [ __ ] kids angelina
jolie collecting all the [ __ ]
infinity stones of of children from
southeast asia and brad pitch is going
along with it being a good husband all
right see that's the difference i see
angelina jolie is laura croft oh she's a
hero and i see brad pitt as tyler durden
i'm like he beats people this is why i
don't like croft tomb raider stealing
treasure that's what she did she went to
cambodia she stole a little treasure
she stole a little treasure oh you know
it's good how do you know they wouldn't
like it over there she's trying to steal
brad pitt's money for her children yes
she stole the children she stole them
you don't know for a fact that these
people really want to give away the kid
they thought it was daycare then gone
that's what they thought oh the white
lady's gonna do daycare she's gonna
build a well and she's gonna do daycare
your child is gone that's why i have
problems with these female action star
movies too because it's like [ __ ] you
can't you tomorrow you can't defend your
kids against [ __ ] tyler durden yeah
how are you [ __ ] damn near a
superhero are you laura crawford tyler
turns up literally a fight champion yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he's not a
champion he was a bad child he could be
fighting you should have put like uh
what was that movie where uh well he's a
gorilla [ __ ] legends of the fall
gorilla one
what gorilla was like friends with a
gorilla or something like that
what brad pitt king kong no
no
that was mark wahlberg joe black joe
black yeah what the [ __ ] what is that i
don't know about that
that's the movie where he dies
who wins laura croft or achilles
achilles achilles is killing his dog a
kid he's a [ __ ] he's all tough and [ __ ]
then you flick his little [ __ ] back
that's what i'm saying the biggest
weakness is your name like you know what
i mean
like you were your name became the name
synonymously but did you see that body
though laura no no
no no
no stupid
bodies
she was hiding laura crawford no she was
fire i mean like don't get me wrong back
in the day like gia if you all want to
see a movie where the heavies are on
display
angelina jolie
the heaves have gotten lopped but back
in the day rpms they got a lot it's
great they did yeah
you hear that that's when brad pitt
started acting up too he was like oh
word yeah like you called cut off that
do you think she did that without
consulting him holy [ __ ] that's probably
why he didn't consult when he worked
with weinstein brad pitt or he was like
you don't want to harass you no more
[ __ ] you ain't got no breasts that's
facts and also she's lying on brad
pitt's name because brad pitt yep was
one was down for the smoke yeah when
weinstein tried to come back winning
paltrow brad pitt went to the [ __ ]
house yeah he was like yo i will beat
the ever work yep yeah yeah apparently
gripped him up by his throat or
something like beat the [ __ ]
you ever come to gwen yo brad is that
[ __ ] dude
he's a good [ __ ] guy he's friends
with matt damon and george clooney is no
big deal
she's walking around with billy bob
thornton's blood and [ __ ] getting stupid
and the accusations are not specific she
just said i feared for the safety of my
children what does that mean why are you
accusing me she would say say the
concrete [ __ ] he did yeah well he had a
temper you can't bro there's a court
case coming up okay no he got acquitted
with the child abuse charges yes he did
yes he did it oh that's what i'm saying
bro this this woman is foul she was also
in the changeling so she knows about
children getting taken
oh
that's that's a morgan freeman movie or
something like that yeah i do remember
the kid gets swapped out and he's like
oh yeah that was inspiration for when
she took them kids
based on trees
her accusations are vague the weinstein
thing she says she was assaulted because
he tried and she escaped
and that's assault cool i can kind of
see that i guess but then also like
how do you not my wife brought this up
she was like didn't how did you not work
with weinstein if you were famous back
then like weinstein touched everything
if he produced a movie you were on yeah
literally
if he produced a movie you were on it's
it's quite possible you were just in a
successful movie
he was a part of everything so like
yeah maybe he maybe he worked with him
in some distance oh he produced his
movie on partner but that [ __ ]
knew he don't be around brad pitt
by the black keys where there's a line
that says uh it's like something about
like your daddy left you
and like now i understand why
whoa you know you know
daddy left you yeah i know that song and
you know what's the next line it ain't
strange to see it ain't strange to see
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and uh
that is angelina jolie
that's angela because john boyd was like
i want nothing to do with this little
[ __ ] and then we were like why like
she's got super heavy she's beautiful
she's super talented yeah and then when
she comes at brad pitt the [ __ ]
legend dog that's the legend that's fall
dawg
bro that's me joe black there wasn't a
gorilla in that movie
that wasn't
[Music]
are you thinking of georgia the jungle
no
me joe black the cover didn't have a
gorilla on it maybe some curious george
mighty joe young
oh yeah is there a gorilla in there
ain't no brad pitt in that dog who's in
that movie i don't know brendan fraser
some [ __ ] sometimes i don't know brad
pitt's in that meet joe black i knew it
where's the gorilla we're trying to mine
[Laughter]
no that's charlize and and brad pitt no
that's not bill paxson bill paxton
wrestling
you're disrespecting brad pitt more than
angelina just now [ __ ] did i mess up you
compared him to the [ __ ]
twister the guy that couldn't even get
the jewel out the titanic you talking
about them like they're just saying
there's 12 monkeys there we go 12 12
monkeys
i got your movie man all i'm saying is
like do not come for brad pitt that
[ __ ] is a legend you're being
disrespectful yeah disrespectful you
better have actual concrete [ __ ] to say
also this triflin ass hatch
remember when
remember when uh my man brad pitt was
with what's the shorty from friends with
the schneizel lean
jennifer aniston she doesn't have a
schnozzle
she got mad no you would be one to talk
when you see
become a little less nauseoline you're
like oh you leaving us no no
she got mad nose jobs that's the change
thing right there that's a real change
thing so
she knew that brad pitt was with uh
shorty yeah and then she came after dude
yeah she did she did they was together
they were together she came after her oh
yeah she ain't [ __ ] she fouls she ain't
[ __ ] she's super fouled they were
together [ __ ] they were married married
they need to run back mr and mrs smith
they need to run that [ __ ] back yeah
that scene where he beats her ass
yeah that's what she's talking about why
should you just going to pull up clips
from that movie
yeah
that's when they hook up i fear for his
safety i fear for my kid's safety around
this killer wow gonna hit him
in that movie
yo this [ __ ] lady bruh i can't
believe her i'm i'm absolutely disgusted
jennifer anderson should get smoked
jennifer anderson should get smoked but
you know what i'm gonna why no she
should pull up on angelina jolie be like
yo what the [ __ ]
love that what gang is this john it's
gay
what kind of twink gang all day baby
[Music]
yeah twig boys you're not a twink bro
yeah no you're not i don't even know
you
yeah you're a beefcake beefcake boys
let's go
okay so what is the deal angelina jolie
what are we doing with her i just can't
believe she acting like this with no
heavy stat you know what i mean she
doesn't talk to her
she don't respect what i said earlier
she don't like good men that's what it
is she keep running all these men out of
her life right she keeps running all
these men out of her life watch what
happens with medics
[Laughter]
you don't know maddox bro that's the
first one where is he from i don't know
bodia
[Laughter]
you mean a bodega yeah
are there any she can't give back yeah
yeah she got receipts they had two real
ones though right yeah
that looked like them yeah oh i'm
assuming the whites shiloh and uh vivian
assuming yeah yeah mark the white ones
well no because you can adopt a white
kid i didn't know you could do that no
you can't you guys i can't do that dawg
you wanna know some internalized racist
[ __ ] i did it so my buddy from florida
kristoff he has an adopted sister
and he told me for all these years she's
like yeah my sister's adopted my sister
you thought that i met her when she was
white yeah yeah she had red hair and i
was like yo kristoff parents are racist
you would be too with the name like
kristoff that sounds like something i
was like
your parents about some lazy ass [ __ ]
just have the kid you don't [ __ ] go
out and buy one that looks just like
come on brad that's right
or do you think that they have
complications
but they got one they had one but
sometimes it takes a lot one and done
maybe yeah but yeah i was like i didn't
know you could adopt white ones that's
sick yeah and also kristoff looked like
he'd be chewing on her [ __ ] uterus
he could have [ __ ] that thing up on
the way out right
yo free kristoff
kristoff we love you homie
we love you this sounds so funny because
he'd be pretending that he's awkward
he's a funny ass re-reader
[Applause]
he leans into that [ __ ] like
i'm awkward but he's not he's actually
regular as [ __ ] knows like mad like
slang like he's like plugged into the
music and everything but he fronts like
he's awkward because it gets him out of
a social interaction that he might not
want to be in that's brilliant it is it
is brilliant but it's also like cut that
[ __ ] out yeah like cut that oh i know
you're not awkward you're just being
ridiculous
right
you regular son smile sir
[ __ ] don't smile so i didn't get
pissed off when people do that [ __ ] bro
like you know a lingard yeah lingo i'm
watching with a cell the other night and
he's [ __ ] funny bro like he's got
great great stuff shouts at lingard
nature hilarious bro and he's so on
stage normal yeah like he's so normal
and charming and like he's just so like
fun to be around like the audience is
just lapping it up and i'm like
fake this [ __ ] around me when i talk to
you at the table yeah
i want this energy with me don't just
stare at me like i'm speaking to you in
[ __ ] swahili or some [ __ ] i need you
faking this
you know how to like comics are always
on all the time keep it on crystal
keep it on a lingard yeah
you know what i said real talk am i
wrong
he oh he's great at being like a person
for 15 minutes at a time son it is he's
i'm watching this guy i'm like there's
no way well some people now if you know
him well enough you see like i'm like oh
i think you can see the moments where
he's trying to be a human being yeah and
he's like getting real close he's
getting real close but he's had to work
on that keep it up work work you better
work this practice around me
you better work
i mean that dude like i think we have to
try a little hard like stop like falling
back into like who you are as a person
effort
this is a joke that i always try to do
about the pigeon toe people yeah it's
like you're not
it's a choice you're making a [ __ ]
choice it's gonna look stupid stupid
what i don't know no no no that's that's
valid where's the flaw in that you're
making a choice to look like an idiot
can't just bop you can't try it it's
literally just opening them up you can't
try that what's wrong your bones grew
incorrectly what is this no it's not
it's the same fat girl so i have thicker
bones
if you eat crazy ice cream if you if
your [ __ ] like that even then you can
like if it's an obtuse angle even if you
have a club foot i think you can fix it
[Laughter]
stretch it a little
you